[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es eine ganz einfach sommerliche Torte.
Ich werde einen Zitronen-Mohn-Torte mit Himbeeren machen.
Nein, ich nenne sie Himbeertorte mit Zitrone und Mohn.
Denn die Himbeeren sollen schon im Vordergrund stehen.
Ja.
Dafür backe ich jetzt erst mal
einen richtig leckeren Rührkuchen.
Dafür verwende ich
200 Gramm weiche Butter,
160 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
vier Eier,
– die sind zimmerwarm –
320 Gramm Mehl,
eineinhalb Teelöffel Backpulver,
etwas Zitronenschale und -saft,
40 Gramm Mohn
und 200 Gramm Buttermilch.
Die ist auch schon etwas erwärmt.
Jetzt nehmt ihr einfach die weiche Butter.
Die darf wirklich richtig weich sein,
nur nicht flüssig.
So lässt sie sich am besten aufschlagen.
Und dann kommt die in die Rührschüssel.
Da kommen Zucker und Salz dazu,
ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt
und dann könnt ihr die Zutaten
so für etwa vier bis fünf Minuten schön cremig verrühren.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Masse schön weißcremig.
So sollte sie aussehen,
also richtig schön geschmeidig.
Und jetzt ist wichtig, dass die Eier wirklich zimmerwarm sind,
damit die Masse eben nicht gerinnt.
Und jetzt, wie Ela so schön sagen würde,
ein Ei nach dem anderen dazu geben.
Das heißt, ein Ei einrühren,
bis es komplett verbunden ist,
und dann erst das nächste.
Okay, es hängt hier gerade so eklig raus.
O mein Gott!
Egal.
Aha!
Das war eleganter.
[Musik]
Schön sieht es aus.
Richtig schön!
Ich kann jetzt das Mehl mit dem Backpulver vermischen.
Die Zutaten kommen jetzt hier rein.
Das Mehl übrigens vorher unbedingt sieben!
Ich habe jetzt ein extra feines Mehl.
Deswegen habe ich es jetzt nicht gesiebt.
Jetzt eine Prise Zitronenabrieb,
nicht zu viel.
Es soll ja nur ganz leicht
nach Zitrone schmecken.
Guckt, nur so wenig.
[Musik]
Den Rest reibe ich aber ab.
Denn den werde ich einfrieren.
[Musik]
Guckt mal!
So viel Zitronenschale!
Und die kann ich jetzt einfach in ein kleines Gefäß geben
und einfrieren.
Jetzt noch etwas Zitronensaft.
[Musik]
Und die Zitronenschale könnt ihr dann
nach dem kompletten Auspressen
einfach als Spülmaschinendeo in die Spülmaschine geben.
Dann ist alles verwertet.
Und dann lohnt es sich auch wirklich, Bio-Zitronen zu kaufen
und unbehandelte.
Jetzt kommt hier noch der Mohn dazu.
[Musik]
Komm, die Buttermilch kriegst du auch in Nahaufnahme.
Okay?
Ui!
Und jetzt wirklich nur noch ganz, ganz kurz verrühren,
nicht zu lange.
Ich hatte Angst davor.
[Musik]
Ich finde...
Ich weiß auch nicht,
aber, sobald Mohn im Teig ist,
ich finde das einfach schön.
Und, Josh, weißt du, was Mohn auf Englisch heißt?
Der englische Name ist so süß!
Ich würde am liebsten öfter Mohn benutzen.
>> JOSH: Ich weiß es tatsächlich nicht.
>> SALLY: Poppy seeds!
Süß, oder?
Und im Deutschen so Mohn.
Im Englischen so poppy seeds.
Das ist so süß!
Ja.
Ich glaube, ich sage ab sofort immer poppy seeds.
Gut.
Jetzt ist der wunderschöne Teig fertig
und wird hier aufgeteilt.
Ich habe hier zwei Backringe bereits
auf 20 cm Durchmesser eingestellt.
Und ich nehme zwei, weil sich dann die Backzeit verkürzt.
Und die passen eben auch wunderbar zu zweit auf ein Blech.
Jetzt schön aufteilen und einfach verstreichen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt kommt der Teig direkt in den Backofen,
wird gebacken.
Und ich warte einfach darauf, bis er fertig ist und abgekühlt ist,
bis es dann gleich weitergeht.
[Musik]
Der Kuchen ist jetzt gebacken und abgekühlt.
Und ich ziehe ihn jetzt direkt hier vom Blech herunter
auf ein Abkühlgitter,
löse den Rahmen jetzt hier mit einem Backformmesser.
Und der kühlt jetzt auch schneller ab,
weil ich eben zwei Backringe verwendet habe.
Da ist der Kuchen einfach dünner
und ist insgesamt einfach schneller fertig.
[Musik]
Und die Backfolie könnt ihr jetzt
ganz einfach darunter wegziehen, indem ihr sie umschlagt
und einfach darunter wegrollt.
Dann geht der Kuchen nicht kaputt
und kühlt schneller ab.
[Musik]
Und jetzt noch mit einem sauberen Geschirrtuch abdecken,
komplett abkühlen lassen
und dann stelle ich ihn
sogar noch mal kurz in den Kühlschrank
und kann mich in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal um die Creme kümmern.
Jetzt sind die beiden Böden komplett abgekühlt
und es geht direkt an die Creme.
Da mache ich jetzt eine Zitronencreme.
Wenn ihr es eher weniger zitronig haben möchtet,
dann lasst die Zitrone einfach weg
und macht einfach eine Vanillecreme zum Beispiel daraus.
Also ich benutze jetzt
wieder eine Zitrone,
– die ist unbehandelt,
das heißt, ich kann die Schale mitverwerten –
80 Gramm Puderzucker,
400 Gramm Quark,
400 Gramm Schlagsahne,
etwas Vanilleextrakt
und San-apart zum Steifschlagen.
Hier habe ich noch etwas Mohn für die Dekoration
und Himbeeren für die Füllung
und natürlich für obendrauf.
Ja.
Was tu ich jetzt zuerst?
Ich nehme erst mal die Zitrone.
Wie gesagt, ich mag es sehr zitronig.
Das heißt, bei mir kommt jetzt hier die ganze Schale mit rein.
Jetzt könntet ihr natürlich sagen,
man hätte ja auch die Schale von vorhin benutzen können.
Ja, aber ich nehme ja jetzt hier noch mal die ganze
und auch den Saft der ganzen Zitrone.
Daher brauche ich jetzt die komplett auf.
[Musik]
Also ich finde, so Zitrone, Mohn und Himbeeren
passen schon mal optisch sehr gut zusammen.
Ja.
Also, wenn die Zitrone sehr groß ist, nehmt nur die Hälfte.
Ich nehme jetzt aber die ganze.
Die ist nicht so arg groß.
Aber so ein bisschen lasse ich übrig.
Das nehme ich gleich in mein Wasser
zum Trinken.
Jetzt gebe ich hier noch den Quark dazu.
Dann Puderzucker rein
und mit Vanilleextrakt kurz verrühren.
[Musik]
Jetzt kurz verrühren.
Hier gebe ich jetzt langsam die Sahne dazu.
Ich mache es aber kurz aus.
Denn
ich habe so eine Bio-Sahne
und die ist immer nicht ganz so homogen.
Das heißt, der Rahm setzt sich gern mal ab.
Und hier solltet ihr darauf achten:
Schlagsahne muss immer eiskalt sein.
Ich dachte immer, ich muss es nicht erwähnen.
Aber, seitdem ich Sturmi und seine Schlagsahne-
Abenteuer kenne,
weiß ich, dass ich sagen muss:
Schlagsahne muss immer eiskalt sein.
Am besten die Rührschüssel kalt, der Schneebesen kalt.
Und dann kann eigentlich nichts schiefgehen.
Ihr dürft halt nicht zu lange rühren.
Wenn ihr nämlich zu lange rührt,
dann zersetzt sich die Sahne in Butter und Rahm,
also in das ganz Flüssige.
Und das wäre halt nicht ganz so gut.
Und wenn sie halt zu warm ist,
lässt sie sich gar nicht erst steif schlagen
und wird dann sofort krisselig und flüssig.
Und dann mit San-apart steif schlagen.
[Musik]
Und gerade beim Sahneschlagen mit der Küchenmaschine
wirklich darauf achten:
Nicht zu lange rühren!
Lieber mal kurz vorher aufhören und gucken,
ob sie schon steif ist.
Die braucht noch ein paar Umdrehungen.
Die ist perfekt.
Weil da kann es schnell passieren.
So schwups, zweimal zu viel
und dann ist die Sahne überschlagen.
Jetzt kann ich die Torte direkt auf der Tortenplatte anrichten.
Und ich nehme dann einfach den Tortendrehteller,
weil ich so eben einfacher arbeiten kann.
Dann so eine Antirutschmatte.
Dann kann auch nichts verrutschen.
So. Beide Böden sind gleichmäßig schön.
Deswegen ist es eigentlich egal,
welcher unten, welcher oben ist.
[Musik]
Dann kommt hier jetzt die Hälfte der Creme drauf.
Ich habe die noch gar nicht probiert, aber
ich denke, sie ist gut.
Das wird so ein Naked Cake.
Ich glaube, ich muss da immer betonen,
die Torte ist nackt, nicht der Mensch.
Und das heißt auch nicht, dass man nackt backen darf.
Nein.
Nackte Torte,
nicht nacktes Backen!
Könnt ihr auch machen,
aber damit will ich nichts zu tun haben.
Ja, ein Kinderkanal sind wir hier,
Kinder und Familien.
Ach, guckt mal!
Und es muss gar nicht gleichmäßig aussehen.
So wirklich so ein bisschen...
Dirty arbeiten, wollte ich sagen, aber dann
ist das, was ich vorhin gesagt habe so...
Okay, ich sage einfach gar nichts mehr.
Jetzt da ein bisschen Mohn draufstreuen.
Wenn ich euch jetzt noch sage,
dass Mohn auf Türkisch haşhaş heißt,
dann sprengt es jetzt...
Okay.
Dann schießt es den Josh hinter der Kamera weg, ey.
Too much information.
Und jetzt kommen hier noch Himbeeren rein.
Oh, wow! Diese Farbkombi!
Ich liebe sie!
[Musik]
Also für innen reicht mir das an Himbeeren.
Denn
da kommt jetzt der Boden drauf.
Der erinnert mich tatsächlich an
meinen Victoria Sponge Cake.
Ja.
Aber den habe ich noch nicht
– nicht verfilmt.
Der ist in meinem Buch "Backen für jeden Anlass".
Und den habe ich damals für VOX gemacht,
als ich in Großbritannien war,
und habe da praktisch so eine British Tea Time gemacht
für Sabine.
Und dann habe ich den Victoria Sponge Cake gemacht
als richtig britischen Kuchen.
So.
Hier die Sahne jetzt auch
schön türmen.
Oh, ich muss aufpassen.
Der Boden rutscht.
Puh!
Ist er gerade
übereinander?
Ja, nicht?
So.
Jetzt auch ein bisschen Mohn.
Himbeeren drauf.
Und dann ab in die Kühlung.
Denn der muss jetzt wirklich gut durchkühlen,
bevor wir ihn durch-
anschneiden können.
Und dann wird er gleich probiert.
[Musik]
Ich glaube, was ich jetzt aber gleich noch mache, ist
– denn es ist ja auch eine Zitronentorte.
Also brauche ich jetzt noch
Zesten.
Da habe ich hier so einen Zestenreißer
– Inspector Gadget, ihr wisst –
und kann jetzt hier schön die Zitronenschale
nehmen und noch mit drauf geben.
[Musik]
Dann habt ihr so schöne kleine Zitronenlöckchen.
Fertig!
Supereinfach, ganz schnell und bestimmt megalecker!
Aber, wie gesagt, erst mal kühlen.
[Musik]
>> SARAH: Die sieht so süß aus!
>> SALLY: Die sieht süß aus, nicht?
>> SARAH: Die ist richtig schön!
>> SALLY: Und die heißt so süß! Die heißt Poppy Seed.
>> SARAH: Wie?
>> SALLY: Ja, Ding...
Mohn heißt doch...
Wie heißt Mohn
auf Englisch?
>> SARAH: Pippy seed?
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> SAMIRA: Poppy.
>> SALLY: Poppy seed!
>> SARAH: Poppy seed?
>> SALLY: Voll süß, nicht?
Mohn auf Deutsch so Mohn.
>> SARAH: Ja, auf Deutsch hört sich alles komisch an.
>> SALLY: Auf Türkisch so haşhaş.
Und auf Englisch so poppy seed.
Das ist so...
Ich weiß nicht,
aber irgendwie muss ich so an Katy Perry denken.
So poppy seed, als wäre das so ein Song von ihr.
Poppy seeds, da-da-da!
>> SARAH: Wir schreiben einen Song "Poppy seed".
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Ich wusste es.
>> SALLY: Ta-daa!
>> SARAH: Ich habe noch... Oh!
Der ist echt schön!
>> SALLY: Ja, und so einfach und so sommerlich!
Ich hoffe, er ist nicht trocken.
Ich würde ihn normalerweise
>> SARAH: Dann die schöne Mintfarbe!
>> SALLY: noch so ein bisschen durchziehen lassen.
Ja, nicht?
>> SARAH: Ja, das passt perfekt!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich finde, Pastellmint, das, ja, passt.
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> SALLY: Probier mal!
>> SARAH: Sind das frische Himbeeren?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Ich bin jetzt nicht davon ausgegangen,
dass du alte nimmst.
>> SALLY: Gefroren sind sie auch nicht.
>> SARAH: Nee, ich meinte, aus dem Garten,
weil du meintest, ihr habt schon Himbeeren.
>> SALLY: Nee, leider...
Also, weil die aus dem Garten sind für die Kinder.
Und die gehen dann immer so hin.
>> SARAH: Woah!
>> SALLY: Und viele haben wir nicht.
>> SARAH: Die Creme!
>> SALLY: Ist gut?
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: So eine Zitronencreme.
>> SALLY: Hihi.
>> SARAH: I love it!
>> SALLY: Also ich hätte tatsächlich
gerne noch mehr Himbeeren so draufgepackt,
dass du bei jedem Biss so eine Himbeere hast.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Aber die kann man ja noch dazu reichen.
Weil die Torte an sich...
Irgendwann ist dann mal genug mit Himbeeren.
Und?
>> SARAH: Mega!
>> SALLY: Ja?
Cool!
>> SARAH: Schmeckt sehr lecker!
>> SALLY: Das freut mich!
>> SARAH: Ich muss jetzt auch üben,
vor der Kamera zu essen.
Das sagt nämlich jeder, warum ich mich immer umdrehe.
>> SALLY: Aha!
>> SARAH: Das habe ich von dir!
>> SALLY: Ja, weil ich einfach die Angewohnheit habe.
Ich esse halt nicht gern vor der Kamera. Ich weiß auch nicht.
>> SARAH: Ja, ich mag das auch nicht.
Weil die ersten Male habe ich so gegessen
>> SALLY: Ja, und...
>> SARAH: und dann habe ich es gesehen und dachte:
"Mach es nie wieder!"
>> SALLY: Ja, genau.
Und ich habe mich dann auch entweder weggedreht
oder so Kamera kurz runter und dann...
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja, egal.
Jedenfalls könnt ihr die Torte gerne ausprobieren.
Das Rezept gibt es zum Nachmachen auf sallys-blog.de
oder als kostenlose App.
Jetzt gucken alle, wie du isst und deinen Mund aufmachst.
Okay.
Sarah schmeckt es.
>> SARAH: Wie macht Ela?
>> SALLY: Ja, Ela macht so.
Und ich glaube, auch die Größe der Torte passt.
Weil die ist so klein und schnuckelig.
Dann macht man sich so ein dünnes Stück ab.
Und dafür ist sie schön hoch.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja, oder?
>> SARAH: Je nachdem, wie man dünn interpretiert,
ist das ein dünnes Stück.
>> SALLY: Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Und bis zum nächsten Mal!
>> SALLY & SARAH: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Oh!
Ich mag die Torte!
My little poppy seeds!
>> SARAH: Poppy seed ist echt?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und
>> SARAH: My little poppy seed!
>> SALLY: Himbeere ist raspberry.
>> SARAH: My little
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> SALLY & SARAH: poppy seed!
>> SARAH: Ta-da, ta-da!
[Musik]